this is post-mubarak Egypt hundreds
possibly thousands of men unleashing the
fury their target is the Israeli embassy
in the way riot police trying to defend
the building inside the mission are at
least six Israeli diplomatic style they
have to be rescued by Egyptian commandos
after being slapped for 13 hours
demonstration is now the right of every
Egyptian one denied by the former
dictator Hosni Mubarak there is no fear
of the state anymore this violence has
been triggered by last month's shooting
dead of five Egyptian border guards by
Israeli forces as they hunted gunman who
killed eight as raise haha are you I
don't care about the risks to my life I
am ready to die taking down the flag I
want to beat the enemies killing my
brothers on the border those killing my
brothers must all die this is the second
anti-israel protest in Cairo a huge
concrete barricade was built after the
first but that proved no obstacle to the
mall
but were handed the Morocco was very
happy and I was asking God to help me
take that Israel's flag I wanted to put
either spike in its place but I didn't
have a live rounds and tear gas were
used against the crowd police insist the
bullets were fired overhead only to
prevent the trouble in spreading both
sides rack up casualties some 450
demonstrators were hurt and forty six
police officers were injured the United
States has expressed its concern and
it's called on Egypt to honor its
international obligations and the threat
is billions of dollars of development
funding money used in part to equip the
Army and the police some analysts
believe this revolution has been
hijacked by groups with a deeper
political agenda it is really a certain
elements was very determined to the rail
Egypt political relations with Israel to
derail the peace treaty with Israel an
emergency cabinet meeting has been
called and the country security forces
on estates of hi loves Egypt's military
rulers must now decide how they deal
with their first real test archis joshi
Skyler's
you
you